- I mean, you've got to be calculated to beat Thanos.
I think the plan that they had in the
first movie where, you know, Star-Lord just,
you know, knocked him out of
whatever daze he was—
I think that same plan, but, you know,
you gotta do it a different way
cuz he's ready for that one again, so—
- With my hands.
- So I would get all the characters
from, like, Cartoon Network, Nickelodeon
and Disney and then
mesh them all together
and then, boom!
There's Thanos.
- Well, you gotta, there's so many options.
I mean, like, honestly, like,
Doctor Strange could do some stuff.
- I would throw a football at him.
I don't know. The man is huge.
- Chris Pratt couldn't have messed up.
It's completely your fault.
- The only way to defeat Thanos is
you've got to take one of his little rock thingys.
So at the beginning of the movie,
I had no idea they were so important,
one of those rocks was just at a train station
in, like, Scotland or something, just bouncing around.
Nobody had a clue that that thing
was gonna end the world with one little thing.
I think what you do need to do is take cuzzy's rocks.
And that's how you win.
I think I would do sleight of hand.
I think I'd steal it right from him
like a magician taking a watch.
And that's how we would save the world.
- Thor could've had a better throw.
There's a lot of things, but—
Now you made me sad.
- You know how they do, like, the fetal position
and, like, if something is bigger and badder.
I'm just going fetal position in hopes he just
takes mercy on me, I mean.
No one can beat him at this point.
I'm not gonna start—
Even though I do have a moustache,
I got no shot still.
- Probably just shoot him.
We gonna do the easy route.